okay so let's get started with the
actual technical content so remember
from last time we gave an overview of
the class we talked about different
types of models that we're going to
explore reflex models state based models
variable based models and logic models
which we'll see throughout the course
but underlying all of this is you know
machine learning because machine
learning is what allows you to take data
and tune the parameters of the model so
you don't have to work as hard designing
the model so in this lecture I'm gonna
start with the simplest of the models of
reflex based models and show how machine
learning can be applied to these type of
models and throughout the class we're
going to talk about different types of
models on how learning well help with
those as well so there's going to be
three parts we're going to talk about
linear predictors which includes
classification and regression loss
minimization which is basically saving
objective function of how you want to
train your machine learning model and
then sarcasstik gradient descent which
is an algorithm that allows you to
actually do the work so let's start with
perhaps the most cliched example of you
know machine learning so you have we
want to do spam classifications so the
input is X an email message and you want
to know whether an email message is a
spam or not spam so we're going to
denote the output of the classifier to
be Y which is in this case either spam
or not spam and our goal is to produce a
predictor F right so a predictor in
general is going to be of a function
that map's some input X to some output Y
in this case it's going to take an email
message and map it to whether the email
message is spam or not okay so there's
many types of prediction problems binary
classification is the simplest one where
the output is one of two possibilities
either yes or no and we're gonna usually
denote this as plus 1 or minus 1
sometimes you also see 1 & 0
there's regression where you're trying
to predict a numerical value for example
let's say housing price
there's a multi-class classification
where why is not just two items but
possibly 100 items maybe cat dog truck
tree and different categories
there's ranking where the output is a
permutation of input this could be
useful for example if the input is a set
of articles or products or webpages and
you want to rank them in some order to
show to a user structured prediction is
where why the output is an object that
is much more complicated perhaps it's a
whole sentence or even an image and it's
something that you have to kind of
construct you have to build this thing
from scratch it's not just a labeling
and there's many more types of
prediction problems but underlying all
of this you know whenever if someone
says I'm gonna do machine learning the
first question you ask is okay what's
the data because without data there's no
learning so we're gonna call an example
XY pair is something that specifies what
the output should be when the input is X
okay and a training data or a set of
examples so the training set is going to
be simply a list or multi set of
examples so you can think about this as
a partial specification of behavior so
remember we're trying to design a system
that has certain certain types of
behaviors and we're going to show you
examples of what that system should do
if I have some email message that has C
just 221 then it's not spam but if it
has lots of dollar signs then it might
be spam and so remember this is not a
full specification behavior these are
ten examples or even a million examples
might not tell you what exactly this
function is supposed to do it's just
examples of what the function could do
on those particular examples okay so
once you have this data so we're gonna
use d-train to denote the data set
remember it's a set of input-output
pairs we're going to push this into a
learning algorithm or a learner and what
is the learning algorithm going to
produce it's going to produce a
predictor so the predictors are F and
the predictor remember is what it's
actually
itself a function that takes an input X
and maps it to an output Y okay so
there's kind of two levels here and you
can understand this in terms of the
modeling inference learning paradigm so
modeling is about the question of what
should the types of predictors after you
should consider our inferences about how
do you compute Y given X and learning is
about how you take data and produce a
predictor so that you can do inference
okay any questions about this so far so
this is pretty high-level and abstracted
in generic right now and this is kind of
kind of on purpose because I want to
highlight how general machine learning
is before going into the specifics of
linear predictors right so this is an
abstract framework okay so let's dig in
a little bit to this actual an actual
problem so just to simplify the email
problem let's consider a task of
predicting whether a string is an email
address or not okay so the input is an
email is a string and the output is it's
a binary classification problem it's
either one if it's an email or minus one
if it's not that's where you want so the
first step of doing linear prediction is
known as feature extraction and the
question you should ask yourself is what
properties of the input ax might be
relevant for predicting the output Y
right so I say a really high line might
be right at this point you're not trying
to encode the actual set of rules that
solves the problem that would you know
involve no learning that would just be
trying to do it directly but instead for
learning you're kind of taking a you
know more of a backseat and you're
saying well here are some hints that
could help you okay
so formally a feature extractor takes an
input and outputs a set of feature named
feature
you pears right so I'll go through an
example here so fi of ABC at gmail.com
what are the properties that might be
useful for determining whether a string
is an email address or not well you
might consider the life of the string if
it's greater than 10 maybe long strings
are less likely to be email addresses
and shorter ones and here the feature
name is length greater than 10 so that's
just kind of label of that feature and
the value of that feature is one
representing its true so it would be 0
if it's false there's another feature
the fraction of alphanumeric characters
right so that happens to be 0.85 which
is the number there might be features
that test for particular you know
letters for example there's a container
at sign well that as you know feature
value of 1 because there is an @ sign
and without com is 1 and without org is
0 because that's not true so and there
you could have many many more features
we'll talk more about features on next
time but the point is that you have a
set of properties you're kind of
distilling down this input which is
could be a string it could be an image
or could be something more complicated
into kind of you know ground-up fashion
that later we'll see how a machine
learning algorithm can take advantage of
ok so you have this feature vector which
has is a list of feature values and
their associated names or labels ok but
later we'll see that the names don't
matter to the learning algorithm so
actually what you should also think
about the feature vector is simply a
list of numbers and just kind of on the
side make a note that oh this you know a
position number 3 corresponds to
contains at and so on
right so I've distilled the the email
address ABC at gmail.com into the list
of numbers 0 or 1 0.85 1 1 0 ok so
that's a feature extraction it's kind of
distilling complex objects into lists of
numbers which we'll see is what the kind
of the lingua franca of these machine
learning algorithm says okay so I'm
gonna write some concepts on the board
there's gonna be a bunch of concepts I'm
gonna introduce and now just keep them
up on the board for reference so feature
vector is a kind of important notion and
it's denoted fee of X on input Sophy
itself sometimes you think about you
call it the feature map which takes an
input and returns a vector and this
notation means that it returns in
general d dimensional vector so a list
of D numbers and the components of this
feature vector we can write down as v1
v2 all the way to feed B of X okay so
this notation is your convenient because
we're going to start shifting our focus
from thinking about the features as
properties of input to features as kind
of mathematical objects so in particular
fee of X is a point in a high
dimensional space so if you have two
features that would be a point in two
dimensional space but in general you
might have a million features so that's
a feature it's a point enough 100 a
million dimensional space so it might be
hard to think about that space but well
we'll see how we can you know deal
without it you know later in a bit okay
so so that's a feature vector you take
an input and return a list of numbers
okay and now the second piece is a
weight vector so let me write down
weight vector so a weight vector is
going to be noted W and this is also a
list of D numbers it's a point in a
d-dimensional space buddy that we're
gonna interpret it differently as we'll
see you later okay so so way to think
about a way to factor is that for each
feature J so for example frac of alpha
we're gonna have a real number WJ that
represents the contribution of that
feature to the prediction so this
contribution is 0.6 so what does this
cut point 6 mean so so the way to think
about
is that you have your weight vector and
you have a feature vector of a
particular input and you want the score
of your prediction is going to be the
dot product between the wave vector and
the feature vector okay so that's
written W dot a fee of X which is
written out as basically looking at all
the features and multiplying the feature
value times the weight of that feature
and summing up all those numbers so for
this example it would be minus 1.2
that's the weight of the first feature
times 1 that's the feature value plus
0.6 times point a 5 and so on and you
know you get this number of four points
five one which is happens to be the
score for this example question
is that supposed to be like an automated
process or yeah so the question is is
the feature extraction manual or
automatic so a fee is going to be
implemented as a function like in code
right you're going to write this
function manually but you know the
function itself is run automatically on
examples later we'll see how you can
actually learn features as well so you
can slowly start to do less of the
manual effort but we're gonna hold off
until next time for that question
yeah so the question is about
interpretation of weights
sometimes weights can have a more
precise meaning in general you can you
can try to read the tea leaves but it's
I don't think there is maybe in general
mathematically precise thing you can say
about the meaning of individual weights
but intuitively and the intuition is
important is that you should think about
each feature as you know a little person
that's gonna make a vote on this
prediction right so you're moaning
either plus yay or nay and the weight of
a particular feature is specifies both
the direction of though whether if
positive weight means that that little
person is voting positive and negative
weight means that it's really negative
and the magnitude of that weight is how
strongly that little person feels about
the prediction right so you know
contains ad is 3 because maybe like at
signs generally do occur in email
addresses but you know the fraction of
alphanumeric characters it's you know
plus so at that level you can have some
intuition but the precise numbers and
why is 0.6 versus 4.5 that's you can't
really say much about that yeah
question keep your networks they can
feel like or weight vectors afterwards
it's still like like so right now we're
focusing on linear classifiers so the
question is what happens if you have
neural net with more layers there's
going to be more dot products but
there's also good it's not just adding
more features there's going to be other
components which we'll get to in a later
lecture yeah yeah so the question is do
the weights have to add up to something
their short answer is no there's
obviously restricted settings where you
might want to normalize the weights or
something but we're not gonna you know
consider that right now um later we'll
see that the magnitude of weight does
tell you you know something okay so so
just to summarize it's important to note
that the the wave vector there's only
one wave vector right you have to find
one set of parameters for every
everybody but the feature vector is per
example so for every employee you get a
new feature vector so and the dot
product of those two weighted
combination features is this as a score
okay so so now let's try to put the
pieces together and define of the actual
predictor all right so remember we have
this a box with an F in it which takes X
and returns Y so what is inside that box
and I've hopefully given you some
intuition let me go to a board and write
a few more things so the score remember
is W dot V of X and this is just going
to be a number and the predictor so
linear predictor well actually let me
call this linear to be more precise it's
a clean your classifier not just a
predictor classifier is just a predictor
that does classification
so a linear classifier denoted F of W so
f is what we're going to use to know
predictors W just means that this
predictor depends on a particular set of
weights and this predictor is going to
look at the score and return the sign of
that score so what is a sign the sign
looks at the score and says is it a
positive a number if it's positive then
we're going to return plus one if it's a
negative number I'm going to return
minus one and if it's zero then you know
I don't care
you can return plus one if you want it
doesn't matter so what this is doing you
remember this the score is either is a
real number so it's either going to be
like kind of leaning towards you know
large value large positive values are
leaning towards us large small negative
values and the sign basically says okay
you got to commit are you which side are
you on are you on the positive side are
you on the negative side and just kind
of discretize it that's what the sign
does okay okay so so let's look at a
simple example because I think a lot of
what I've said before is kind of more
the formal machinery behind and the math
behind how it works but it's really
useful to have some geometric intuition
because then you can draw some pictures
okay so let's consider this case so we
have a wave vector which is 2 1 2 minus
1 and a feature vector which is a 2 0
and another feature vector which is 0 2
+ 2 4 ok so there's only two dimensions
so I can try to draw them on a board so
let's try to do that ok so here is a
two-dimensional plot and let's draw the
fee or the wave vector first ok so the
wave vector is going to be at 2 - 1 okay
so that's this point and the way to
think about the wave vector is not that
point but actually the the vector going
from the origin to that point for
reasons I'll become clear later ok so
that's the that's the weight ok and then
what about the other points so we have 2
0 0 2 so 2 0 is here 0 2 is here and 2 4
is here right ok so we have 3 points
here ok so how do I think about what
this weight vector is is doing so just
just for reference remember the
classifier is looking at the sign of W
dot V of X ok so let's try to do
classification on these three points ok
so W is let me write alpha 2 1 and this
is 0 2 so what's the score when I do W
dot V of X here
it's 4 right because this is 2 0 2 2 4
so this is just a dot product that's 4
and take the sign what's the sine of 4 1
ok so that means I'm going to label this
point as a positive right positive point
ok what about 0 2 actually sorry this is
just to be a minus 1 right
okay this is 2-1 okay so if I take the
dot product between this I get minus two
and then the sine of minus two is is
minus one okay so that's a minus and
what about this one so what's the dot
product there it's going to be zero okay
so so this classifier will classify this
point as a positive this is a negative
and this one I don't know okay so we can
fill in more points but but you know
does anyone see kind of maybe a more
general pattern I don't want to have to
fill in the entire board with
classifications yeah yeah so so let's
try to draw the orthogonal oh this needs
to go through that line okay okay so
let's draw the orthogonal so this is a
right angle
okay and what that gentleman said is
that the points any point over here
because it has acute angle with W is
going to be classified as positive so
all this stuff is you know positive
positive positive positive and
everything over here because that's
obtuse angle with the W it's going to be
negative so everything over here is
negative and then everything on this
line is going to be zero okay so so I
don't know
okay and this line is called the
decision boundary which is a concept not
just for linear classifiers but whenever
you have any sort of classifier that
this resume boundary is the separation
between the regions of the space where
the classification is positive versus
negative okay and in this case it's it
separates because it's we have linear
classifiers the decision boundary is
straight and we're just separating the
the space into you know two house if you
were in three dimensions this vector
would still be just a vector but this
decision boundary would be a plane so
you can think about it as you know
coming out of the board if you want but
I'm not gonna try to draw that and
that's that's kind of the geometric
interpretation of how linear classifiers
you know work here question yeah yeah so
that's a good point so the the
observation is that no matter if you
scale this weight by two it's actually
going to still have the same decision
boundaries so the magnitude of the
weight doesn't matter it's the direction
that matters so this is true for just
making a prediction when we look at
learning the magnitude of the weight
will matter because we're going to you
know consider other more nuanced loss
functions
[Music]
okay so let's move on any questions
about linear predictors so so far what
we've done is we haven't done any
learning right if you've you know notice
we've just simply defined the set of
predictors that we're interested in so
we have feature vector we have wave
vectors multiplying together get a score
and then you can send them through a
sine function you get these linear
classifiers right there's no
specification of data yet okay so now
let's actually turn to do some learning
so remember this framework learning
needs to take some data and return a
predictor and our predictors are
specified by a weight vector so you can
equivalently think about the learning
algorithm is outputting a weight vector
if you want for linear classifiers and
let's unpack the learner so the learning
algorithm is going to be based on
optimization which we started reviewing
last lecture which separates what you
want to compute from how you want to
compute it so we're going to first
define an optimization problem which is
specifies what properties we want a
classifier to have in terms of the data
and then we're going to figure out how
to actually optimize this and this
modularity is actually really really
powerful yes and it allows people to go
ahead and work on different types of
criteria for and different types of
models separately from the people who
actually develop general-purpose
algorithms and this has served to kind
of the field of machine learning quite
well okay so let's start with
optimization problem so there's an
important concept call it a loss
function
and this is a super general idea that's
using the machine learning statistics so
a loss function takes a particular
example X Y and a weight vector and
returns a number and this is the reading
number represents how unhappy we would
be if we use the predictor given by W to
make a prediction on X when the correct
output is y okay so it's a little bit of
a mouthful but this basically is trying
to characterize you know if you handed
me a classifier and I go on to this
example and try to classify it is it
going to get a ride or is it gonna get
it wrong so high loss is bad you don't
want to lose and low loss is good so
normally zero loss is the the best you
can kind of hope for okay so let's do
figure out the loss function for binary
classification here so just some
notation the correct label is denoted Y
and the predicted label remember is the
score sent through the sine function and
that's going to give you some a
particularly Bowl and let's look at this
example
so W equals to minus one fee of x equals
to zero and y equals minus one okay so
we already defined the score as on
example is w of X which is how confident
we're predicting Maya plus one that's a
way to interpret this okay so what's the
score of this for this particular
example again it's 4 right which means
that you know we're kind of kind of
positive that it's you know a plus one
yeah question
[Music]
or the output yeah so the question is
whether the output of loss function is
usually a single and number or not in
most cases it is for basically all
practical cases and you should think
about the loss functions out bringing in
a single number the inputs can be you
know crazy high dimensional yeah there
are cases where you might have multiple
objectives that you're trying to
optimize at once but in this class it's
always going to be you know one
dimensional like maybe you care about
you know both time and space or accuracy
but robustness or something sometimes
you have multi objective optimization
but that's the psych way beyond the
scope of this class okay so we have a
score and now we're gonna define margin
so let me okay so let's let's actually
do this so we're talking about
classification I'm gonna sneak
regression in in a bit so score is W of
X this is how confident we are about +1
and the margin is the score times y and
this relies on Y being plus one or minus
one so this might seem a little bit
mysterious but let's try to you know
decipher that here so in this example
the score is four so what's the margin
you multiply by -1 so the margin is
minus four right and the margins
interpretation is how correct we are
right so imagine the correct answer is
if if the score in the margin have the
same sign then you're gonna get positive
numbers and then the the confident the
more confident you are then the more
correct you are but if Y is -1 and the
score is positive then the margin is
gonna be negative which means that
you're going to be confidently wrong
which is bad okay so just to see if we
kind of understand what's going on so
when does a binary classifier making
mistake on a given example so I'm gonna
ask for a kind of a show of hands how
many people think gets its when the
margin is less than zero okay I guess we
can kind of stop there I used to do
these online quizzes where it was an
anonymous but we're not doing that this
year okay so yes the margin is less than
0 when the margin is less than zero that
means Y and the score are different
signs which means that you're making a
mistake okay so now we have the notion
of a margin let's define something
called the zero of one loss and it's
called zero one because it returns
either a zero or one very creative so
the loss function is simply did you make
a mistake or not okay so this notation
let's try to tie for a bit so if f of X
here is the prediction when the input is
X and not equal Y is saying did you make
a mistake
so that's think about it as a boolean
and this one bracket is just notation
it's called an indicator function that
takes a condition and returns either 1
or 0 so if if the condition is true then
it's going to return a 1 and the
condition is false it returns
okay so all this is doing is basically
returning a one if you made a mistake
and 0 if you didn't make a mistake okay
and we can write that as follows we can
write that as the margin less or equal
to zero right because on the previous
slide if the margin is less than zero
then we've made a mistake and we should
incur a loss of one and if the margin is
greater than zero then we didn't make a
mistake and we should we concur a loss
of zero okay all right so it will be
useful to draw these loss functions
pictorially like this okay so on the
access x-axis here we're going to show
the margin right remember the margin is
how correct you are and on the y-axis
we're going to show the the loss
function which is how much you're going
to suffer for it okay so remember the
margin if the margin is positive that
means you're getting a right which means
that the loss is zero but if the margin
is less than zero that means you're
getting it wrong and the losses one okay
so this is a zero one loss
that's the this thing the visual that
you should have in mind when you think
about your loss yeah
yeah so there's this kind of boundary
condition of one X what happens exactly
at zero that I'm trying to sweep under
the rug because it's not terribly
important here it's less we go to zero
to be kind of on the safe side so if you
don't know you're also going to get it
wrong otherwise you could always just
return zero and then do be that that's
you don't want that okay so is it any
questions about kind of binary
classification so far so we've set up
these linear predictors and I've defined
the zero and loss as a way to capture
how unhappy we would be if we had a
classifier that was operating on a
particular data point X Y so just as I'm
gonna go on a little bit of a digression
and talk about linear regression and and
the reason I'm doing this is that lots
minimization is such a powerful in
general framework and it transcends you
know all of these you know linear
classifiers regression setups so I want
to kind of emphasize the overall of an
overall story so I'm gonna give you a
bunch of different examples
classification regression side by side
so we can actually see how they compare
and hopefully they're the common
denominator will kind of emerge more
clearly from that ok so we talked a
little bit about linear regression in
the last lecture right so linear
regression in some sense is simpler than
the classification because if you have a
linear predictor and you get to score W
dot V of X it's already a real number so
in linear regression you simply return
that real number and you call that your
prediction okay
okay so now we let's move towards to
find your loss function so there's going
to be a concept that's going to be
useful it's called the residual which is
against kind of trying to capture how
wrong you are so here is a particular
linear predictor linear regressor and
it's making predictions all along you
know for different values of X and
here's the data point of fear of X Y
okay so the residual is the difference
between the true value Y and the
predictive value Y okay and in
particular it's the amount by which the
prediction is overshooting
you know the target okay so this is this
is a difference and if you square the
difference you get something called the
squared loss so this is something we
mentioned last lecture residual can be
either negative or positive but errors
either if you're very positive or very
negative that's bad and squaring a mixer
so that you're gonna you know suffer
equally for errors in both directions
okay so the square loss is the residual
squared so let's do this kind of simple
example so here we have our wave vector
2 minus 1 the feature vector is to 0
what's the score it's for y is million
minus 1 so the residual is 4 minus minus
1 which is 5 and it's 5 squared is 25 so
the squared loss on this particular
example is 25
okay so let's plot this so just like we
did it for a zero on loss so let's see
what this loss function looks like so
the the horizontal axis here instead of
being the margin is going to be this
quantity for regression called the
residual it's going to be the difference
between the prediction and the true
target and I'm gonna plot the loss
function and this loss function is just
you know the squared function right so
with if the residual is zero then the
loss is zero if as the residual grows in
either direction then I'm going to pay
something for it and it's a quadratic
penalty which means that it actually
grows you know pretty fast so if I'm you
know the residual is 10 then paying a
hundred okay so so that's the squared
loss there's also another loss I'll
throw in here called the absolute
deviation loss and this might actually
be the last day if you didn't know about
regression you might immediately come to
it's basically the absolute difference
between the prediction and the actual
true target turns out the squared loss
there's a kind of a longer discussion
about you know which loss function you
know makes sense the the salient points
here are that the absolute deviation
loss is kind of has this kink here and
so it's not smooth sometimes it makes it
harder to optimize but the square loss
also has this kind of thing that blows
up which means that it's it really
doesn't like having outliers or really
large values because it's going to
you're gonna pay a lot for it but at
this level just think about this as you
know different losses there's also
something called the hueber loss which a
kind of combines both of these is smooth
and also grows linearly instead of
quadratically okay so we have both
classification
um regression we can define margins and
residuals we get either different loss
functions out of it right and now we
want to minimize the loss okay so it
turns out that for one example this is
really easy right so if I if I told you
okay how do I minimize the loss here
well okay it's zero done so that's not
super interesting and this corresponds
to the fact that you know if you have a
classifier you trust trying to fit at
one point it's really not that hard so
that's kind of not the point the point
of machine learning is that you have to
fit all of them remember you only get
one one weight vector you have all these
examples you have a million examples you
want to find one weight vector that kind
of balances errors across all of them
and in general you might not be able to
achieve loss of zero right so tough
lanka life is hard
so you have to make trade-offs you know
which examples are you going to kind of
sacrifice for the good of other examples
and this is actually a lot of where you
know issues around fairness of machine
learning actually come in because in
cases where you can't actually make a
prediction that's you know equally good
for everyone
you know how do you actually you know
responsibly make these trade-offs but
you know that's a that's a broader topic
let's just focus on trade-offs defined
by the simple sum over all the last
example so let's just say we want to
minimize the average loss over all the
examples okay so once we have these loss
functions if you averaged over the
training set you get something which
we're going to call the trained loss and
that's a function of W right so a loss
is on a particular example of train
losses on the entire data set
[Music]
okay so any questions about this so far
okay so there is this discussion about
which regression loss to use which I'm
going to skip you can feel free to read
into the notes if you're interested the
punchline is that if you want things
that look like the mean square loss if
you want things that look like the media
and use the absolute deviation loss but
I'll skip that for now yeah when do
people start thinking of regressions
like in terms of loss minimization so
regression has least squares regression
is from like the early 1800s so it's
been around for is you know kind of you
could call it the first machine learning
that was ever done if you if you want I
guess the loss minimization framework is
it's hard to kind of pinpoint a
particular point in time you know it's
it's kind of not a terribly you know
it's not like a you know innovation in
some sense it's just more of a at least
right now it's kind of a pedagogical
tool to organize all the different
methods that exist yeah
do you mean that like in that particular
training training set the median work
even highest I casinos confident whereas
like yeah so um I don't want to get into
this examples but briefly if you have
three points that you you can't exactly
fit perfectly you if you use absolute
deviation then you're gonna find the
median value you're gonna basically
predict the median value and if you use
the square laws you're going to predict
the mean value but I'm happy to talk
offline okay so what we've talked about
so far is we have these wonderful linear
predictors which are driven by feature
vectors and weight vectors and now we
can define a bunch of different loss
functions that capture you know how we
care about you know regression and
classification and now let's try to
actually do some real machine learning
how do you actually optimize these
objectives so remember the learner is
going so now we've talked about the
optimization problem which is minimizing
the training loss we'll come back to
that next lecture and then now we're
going to talk about home to my
suggestion algorithm okay so what is the
optimization problem now remember last
time we said okay let's just abstract
away from the details a little bit let's
not worry about if it's the square loss
or you know some other loss let's just
think about as they're kind of abstract
function so in one dimension the
training loss might look something like
this you have a single weight and for
each weight you have a number which is
your loss on your training examples okay
and you want to find this point so in
two dimensions
it looks something like this and let me
try and actually draw this because I
think you'll be useful
[Music]
okay so in two dimensions
what optimization looks like is this
follow so I'm going to I'm now plotting
[Music]
w1 and w2 which are the two components
of this two-dimensional weight vector so
for every point I have a weight vector
and that value is going to be the loss
of the training loss and it's it's
pretty standard in these settings to
draw what are called level curves so
let's do this
so each curve here is a ring of points
where the function value is identical so
if you look at turning maps those are
level curves so you know kind of what
I'm talking about so this is the minimum
and as you kind of grow out you get
larger and larger okay I'll keep on
doing this for a little bit okay all
right
and the goal is to find the minimum okay
all right so how are we gonna do this
so yeah question yeah why am i assuming
there is a single minimum in general for
arbitrary loss functions there's no
necessary a single minimum I'm just
doing this for simplicity it turns out
to be true for you know many of these
linear classifiers
okay so last time we talked about
gradient descent right and the idea
behind gradient descent is that well I
don't know where this is so let's just
start at zero as good as any place and
what I'm going to do at zero is I'm
going to compute the gradient so the
gradient is this vector that's
perpendicular to the level curves so the
gradients is going to point in this
direction that says hey in this
direction is where the function is
increasing the most dramatically and
gradient ascent says take some it goes
in the opposite direction right because
remember we want to minimize loss so I'm
gonna go here
and now I'm hopefully reduce my function
value not necessarily but we hope that's
that's a case now we compute the granny
again the Iranian says you know maybe
it's pointing this way so I go in that
direction and maybe now it's pointing
this way and I keep on going this is a
little bit made-up but hopefully
eventually I get to the Georgian and you
know I'm I'm kind of simplifying things
quite a bit here so in there's a whole
field of optimization that studies
exactly what kind of functions you can
optimize and how gradient descent when
it works and when it doesn't I'm just
going to kind of go through the
mechanics now and differ that kind of
the formal proofs of when this actually
works until later okay so that's kind of
the the schema of how great descent
works so in code this looks like this so
initialized at zero and then lupine some
number of iterations which let's for
simplicity just think there's a fixed
number of iterations and then I'm gonna
pick up my weights compute the gradient
move in the opposite direction and then
there's going to be a step size that
tells me how fast I want to you know
make progress okay and we'll come back
to you know what the step size does
later
okay so let's specialize it to least
squares regression so we kind of did
this last week but just to kind of
review so the training loss for least
squares every question is this so
remember it's an average over the loss
of individual examples and the loss of a
particular example is the residual
squared so that's this expression and
then all we have to do is compute the
gradient and you know if you remember
your calculus it's just I've use a chain
rule so this two comes down here you
have the you know the residual times the
derivative of what's inside here and the
gradient with respect to W is
fee of X okay so last time we did this
in Python in one dimension so in one
dimension hopefully all of you should
feel comfortable doing this because this
is just kind of basic calculus here we
have W is a vector so we're not taking
derivatives but we're taking gradients
so there's you know some things to be
wary of but in this case it's often kind
of useful to double check that well
the gradient version actually matches
the the single dimensional version and
you know as well because last time
remember we have X out here and one
thing to know here is that there's a
prediction - target that's a residual so
the gradient is driven by you know the
kind of this quantity so if the
prediction equals the target what's a
gradient it's going to be zero which is
kind of what you want if you're already
getting the answer correct then you
shouldn't want to move your your weights
right so often you know we can do things
in the abstract and everything will work
but you know it's it's often a good idea
to write down some objective functions
take the gradient and see if gradient
descent on using these gradients that
you computed is kind of a sensible thing
because there's kind of many layers you
can understand and get intuition for
this stuff as a kind of abstract level
optimization or kind of add the
algorithmic level like you pick up an
example is it sensible to update when
the gradient or then when the prediction
equals to target okay so so let's take
the code that we from how from last time
and I'm going to expand on it a little
bit and hopefully set the stage for
doing stochastic gradient okay so so
last time we had gradient descent
okay so remember last time we define a
set of points we define the function
which is the trained loss here we define
the derivative of the function and then
we have great at descent
okay so I'm gonna do a little bit of
housecleaning just don't mind me okay so
I'm gonna make this a little bit more
explicit what this algorithm is Green
descent depends on a function a
derivative function and let's say you
know the dimensionality and I can call
this gradient with FTF and in this case
it's D where D equals two okay you know
I want to kind of separate this is that
kind of algorithms and this is you know
modeling so this is what we want to
compute and this is you know how we
compute it okay and this code should
still work okay all right so what I'm
gonna do now is upgrade this to vector
strong remember the executor is just a
number
right well we want to support vectors so
in Python we're gonna import numpy so
which is nice
vector and matrix library and I'm gonna
make some you know arrays here which and
this is just going to be a
one-dimensional array so it's not that
exciting so this this WX becomes
the actual dot on you to call and I
think and W it needs to be emptied our
zeros okay alright so that should still
run actually sorry this just
one-dimensional okay so remember last
time we ran this this program and it
starts out with some weights and then it
converges to 0.8 and the function value
kind of keeps on going down okay all
right so let's let's try to you know
it's really hard to kind of see whether
this algorithm is any doing anything
interesting because we only have two
points it's kind of trivial so how do we
go about you know because I'm gonna also
implements cassock radius and how do we
have kind of a test case to see if this
algorithm is you're working so there's
kind of this technique which I really
like and it's you know which is to call
you know generate artificial data and
idea is that you know what is learning
you're learning is you're taking a data
set and you're trying to fit find the
weights that best fit that data set but
in general if I generate some are below
the dais I have no idea what the right
kind of quote unquote right answer is so
this I think where I go backwards I say
okay let's let's decide what the right
answer is so let's say the right answer
is in one two three four five so it's a
five dimensional problem okay
and I'm gonna generate some data based
on that so that this weight vector is
kind of good for that data I'm gonna
skip all my breaks in this lecture so
I'm gonna generate a bunch of points so
let's stare at 10,000 points
the nice thing about artificial data is
you can generate as much as you want
there's a question yeah oh so true W
just means like the correct the ground
truth W so W is a weight vector so this
kind of going backwards remember I want
to fit the way back here but I'm just
kind of saying this is the right answer
so I want to make sure that the
algorithm actually recovers okay so I'm
gonna generate some random dude up so
there's a nice function random dot R and
n which generates a random D dimensional
vector and why I'm going to set Y which
I said Y to
yeah so so I'm gonna do regression so I
want to do true W dot X right so I mean
if you think about it if I took this
data and I found it like true why W is
the right thing that will get 0 lies
here ok but I'm gonna make life a little
bit more interesting and we're gonna add
some noise okay so let's print out what
that looks like
also I should add it to my data set so
okay so this is my data set okay
I mean can't really tell what's going on
but but you can look at the code and you
you can assure yourself that this data
has structure in it okay so let's get
rid of this print statement and let's
train and see what happens so let's okay
oh one thing I forgot to do so if you
notice that the objective functions that
I've you're in down they haven't divided
by the number of data points I want the
average lost not the song it turns out
that you know if you have the Sun then
things get really big and blow up so we
just normalize that okay so okay so it's
training its training actually so let me
do more iterations so I did 100
iterations let's do a thousand
iterations okay so you know the function
values going down that's always
something to know good to check and you
can see the weights are kind of slowly
getting to you know what appears to be
one two three four or five right okay so
you know this is a hard proof but it's
kind of evidence that this learning
algorithm is actually kind of doing the
right thing
okay so now let's see if I add you know
more points so I now have a hundred
thousand points now it gets slower and
you'll know hopefully I get there one
day but I'm just gonna kill it
okay any questions about its right
terminal got screwed up okay so what I
do here I define loss functions took the
derivatives the gradient descent is what
we implemented last time and the only
thing different I did this time is
generating a data set so I can kind of
check whether grading descent is working
yeah question
the question is whether the fact that
the cranium is a residual allows their
algorithm to learn from under over
predictions yeah so the gradient is if
you think about it yeah that's good
intuition so if you look at if you're
over predicting right that means the
gradients kind of assumed that this is
like one so that means this is going to
be positive which means that hey if you
up that weight you're gonna over predict
more and more incur more loss
so my subtracting the gradient you're
kind of pushing the weights out in the
other direction and same for when you're
under predicting yeah so that's good
intuition to have yeah
what is the effect of the noise the
effect of noise it makes the problem of
a little bit you know harder so that it
takes more examples to learn if you shut
off the noise then it will you know we
can try it I have never done this before
but presumably you'll learn you know
faster but maybe not the noise doesn't
you know that much
okay so so let's say you have you know
like five hundred examine examples you
know that's quite a few examples NL you
know this algorithm runs you know pretty
slowly right and in modern machine
learning you have you know millions a
hundred millions of examples so grain
descent is gonna be you know pretty slow
so how can we speed things up a lot of
that and what's the problem here
well if you look at the the what the
algorithm is doing its iterating and
each iteration its computing the grading
of the training loss and the training
loss is just average of all the points
which means that you have to go through
all the points and compute there your
law grading of the loss and you add
everything up and that's what is
expensive and you know takes time so you
know you might wonder well how can you
avoid this
I mean you if you wanted to create a
send you have to go through all your
points and the the key insight behind
stochastic gradient sent is that well
maybe maybe you don't have to do that so
maybe you know here here's some
intuition right so what what is this
gradient so this gradient is actually
the sum of all the gradients from all
the examples in your training center
right so you have 500,000 points adding
to that
so actually what this gradient is is
it's actually kind of sum of different
things which are may be pointing in
slightly different directions which all
averaged out to this direction okay
so maybe you can actually not average
all of them but you can average just a
couple or maybe even in an extreme case
you can just like take one of them and
just you know march in that direction so
so here's the idea behind stochastic
gradient descent so instead of doing
gradient descent we're gonna change the
algorithm to say for each example in the
training set I'm just gonna pick it up
and just update you know it's instead of
like sitting down and looking all over
all the training samples and thinking
really hard I'm just gonna pick up one
training example and update right away
so we're kind of the key idea here it's
it's not about quality it's about
quantity maybe not the world's best life
lesson but it seems to work in it work
in here and then there's also this
question of watch - the step size B and
in generally in stochastic gradient is
and it's actually even a bit more
important because when you're updating
on into each individual example you're
getting kind of noisy estimates of their
actual gradient and and people often ask
me like oh how should I set my step size
and you know and the answer is like
there is no formula I mean there are
formulas but there's no kind of
definitive answer here's some general
guidance
so if step size is small sorry really
close to zero that means you're taking
tiny steps right that means that it'll
take longer to get where you want to go
but you're kind of proceeding cautiously
so you it's less likely you're gonna you
know if you mess up and go in the wrong
direction you're not gonna go too far in
the wrong direction conversely if you
have a to be really really large then
you you know it's like a racecar you
kind of drive really fast but you might
just kind of bounce around a lot so
pictorially what I'm this looks like is
that you know here's maybe a moderate
step size but if you're taking steps
really big steps
you know you might go over here and then
you jump around and then maybe maybe you
ran up in the right place but maybe
sometimes you can actually get flung off
out
of orbit and you know diverse infinity
which is a bad situation so there's many
ways to set the step size you can send
it to our you know constant you could
usually have to you know tune it or you
can set it to be decreasing the
intuition being that as you optimize and
get closer to the optimum you kind of
want to slow down right like if you
you're coming on a freeway you're
driving really fast but once you get to
your house you probably don't want to be
like driving 60 miles an hour okay so
actually I didn't implement stochastic
gradient so let me do that so let's
let's try to get Tsukasa cranium up and
going here okay so so the interface that
sarcastic gradient changes so right so
do ingredients and all we need is a
function and it just kind of computes
the sum of all the training examples so
sarcastic gradient I'm just no SF for
stochastic radio I'm gonna take an index
I and I'm going to update on the eighth
point only so I'm going to only compute
the loss on the ice point and same
further its derivative gonna look at the
ice point and just compute their grinny
on that ice point okay and this should
be called STF okay so now instead of
doing gradient descent
let's do circus a gradient descent I
mean I'm gonna pass an SD s FS DF D and
the number of points because I need to
know how many points there are now copy
green new sand and it's basically the
same function I'm just gonna stick
another for loop in there so stochastic
gradient descent it's gonna take this
sarcastic functions classic gradient the
dimension Audion and okay so now before
I was just going through number of
iterations and now right I'm not gonna
try to compute the value over all the
training examples I'm going to
loop over all the points and I'm going
to call just evaluate the function at
that point I it compute the gradient at
that point hi instead of the entire
dataset and then everything else is the
same
I mean one other thing I'll do here is
that I'll use a different step size
schedule so one divided by number of
updates so I want its so that the number
of the step sizes kind of decrease over
time okay so I start with 8 equals 1 and
then it's 1/2 and then it's 1/3 and it's
1/4 and it keeps on going down sometimes
you can put a square root and that's
more typical in some cases but I'm not
gonna worry about that details too much
question
yeah so question is the word stochastic
means that there should be some
randomness here and you know technically
speaking the the sarcastic gradient
descent is where you're sampling a
random point and then you're updating on
it I'm cheating a little bit because I'm
iterating over all the points you know
in practice if you have a lot of points
and you randomize the order it's it kind
of you know it's similar but it's yeah
there is a kind of a technical
difference that I'm trying to hide okay
so so this is the Cassegrain descent to
iterate you know go over all the points
and just you know update okay so let's
see if this works okay
I don't think that worked maybe hmm
let's see what happened here I did try
it on a hundred thousand points maybe
that works I know that didn't work
either
and you won't see the problem oh so I'm
printing this out at the at the end of
each iteration so that should be fine
really this should work
so gradient descent was working right
maybe I'll try it's probably not the
best idea to be debugging this live
okay let's like to make sure gradient
descent works okay so that was working
right okay so it's a casick gradient
descent I mean it's a bit really fast
and converges but it doesn't converge
the right answer yeah but that should
get incremented to one so that it might
be okay so I do have a version of this
code that does work so what am I doing
here that's different okay have some
water maybe I need some like
okay so this version works yeah yeah
that's that's probably good okay all
right now it works thank you um so yeah
yeah this is a good a lesson is that
when you're dividing this needs to be
one actually in Python 3 this is not a
problem but I'm so I'm Python 2 for some
reason but this should be a 1 point 0
divided by num updates otherwise I was
getting okay so why is it yeah okay okay
let's let's go back to 500,000 okay okay
so one full sweep over the data is the
same amount of time but you notice that
immediately already converges to 1 2 3 4
5 right so this is like way way faster
than gradient descent remember just so
you kind of compare gradient descent is
you run it and after one step it's like
not even close right yeah
Breezie what noise levels do you have to
have until gradient descent becomes
better so it is true that if you have
more noise then greatness that might be
the category and in SEM can be unstable
there might be ways to mitigate that
with step size choices but yeah probably
you have to add a lot of noise for
stochastic rate have to be really bad I
mean this isn't some sense you know if
you take a step back and think about
what's going on is a problem it's a five
dimensional problem there's only five
numbers and I'm feeding at half a
million data points right there aren't
there's not that much to learn here and
so there's a lot of redundancy in the
data set and generally actually this is
true like you know large data set
there's going to be a lot of you know
redundancy so going through all the data
and then trying to make an informed
decision is you know pretty wasteful
where sometimes you can just kind of get
a representative sample from one example
or more is common to do like kind of
mini batches where you maybe grab a
hundred examples and you update on that
which is so there's a way to somewhere
between the category a greater percent
okay let me move on
okay summary so far we have linear
predictors which are based on scores so
linear prediction include both
classifiers and requesters we can do
loss minimization and we can if we
implement it correctly we can do SGD
okay so that was I'm kind of switching
things I hope you're kind of following
along I introduced binary classification
and then I did all the optimization for
linear regression so now let's go back
to classification and see if we could do
Socastee gradient descent here
okay so first classification remember we
decided that the zero one loss is the
thing we want we want to minimize the
number of mistakes you know who can
argue with that so remember what does
zero one loss look like it looks like
this okay so what happens if I try to
run stochastic gradient descent on this
I mean I could run the code
but yeah it's it won't work right and
why won't it work yeah so two popular
answers are it's not differentiable
that's one problem but I think that the
the bigger problem is kind of a deeper
problem is that what is it what is the
gradient zero it's like zero basically
everywhere except for at this point
which you know it doesn't remember so so
as we learned that if you try to update
with a grading of zero then you won't
move your weights right so the gradient
descent will not work on the zero on
loss so that's that's kind of
unfortunate so how should we fix this
problem yeah yeah let's let's make the
gradient at zero let's skew things so
there's one loss which I'm gonna
introduce called the hinge loss which
does exactly that so when we write the
hinge loss down and the hinge loss is
basically is zero here when the margin
is greater equal one and rises linearly
so if you've gone in a correct by a
margin of one so you're kind of pretty
safely on the air side of I'm getting it
correct then we won't charge you
anything but as soon as you start you
know dip it into this area we're gonna
charge you a kind of a linear amount and
your loss is gonna grow linearly so
there's some reasons why this is a good
idea so it upper bounds the zero and
loss it's has a property called known as
convexity which means that if you
actually run the gradient descent you're
actually going to converge through the
global optimum I'm not going to get into
that and so that's you know that's a
hinge loss so what remains to be done is
to compute the gradient of this your
hinge loss okay so how do you compute
this gradient
so in some sense it's a trick question
because the gradient doesn't exist
because it's not differentiable
everywhere but we're gonna pretend that
little point doesn't exist okay
so so what is this hinge loss the hinge
loss is actually two functions right
there's a zero function here and then
there's like this one minus x function
so what am i plotting here I'm plotting
them with the margin and the loss okay
so this is the zero function and this is
a 1 minus W dot V of X 1 and the hinge
loss is just the maximum of these two
function so at every point I'm just
taking the top function so that's how
I'm able to trace out this this car ok
all right so if I want to take the
gradient of this function you know you
can try to do the math but let's think
through it you know what what should the
gradient be well if we're here what
should the gradient be its 0 and if I'm
here what should agree everything it
should be the whatever the grading of
this function is right so in general
when you have a grading of of this kind
of Max you have to kind of break it up
into cases and depending on where you
are you you have a different case so
loss is equal to if I'm over here and
what's the condition for being over here
if the margin is greater than 1 right
and then otherwise I'm going to take the
gradient of this with respect to W which
is going to be minus V of X Y you know
otherwise
[Music]
so again we can try to interpret the
gradient of the hinge laws so remember
you in stochastic gradient descent you
have a wave vector and you're gonna pick
up an example and you say oh let's
compute the gradient move away from it
so if you're getting an example right
then the gray in zero don't move which
is the right thing to do and otherwise
you're going to move in the direction
because you're minus minus of V of X Y
which kind of imprints this example into
your wave vector so and you can formally
show that it actually increases your
margin after you do this okay yeah
what's the significance of the margin
being one this is a little bit arbitrary
you just kind of sending on nonzero
value and and you know in support vector
machines you set it to 1 and then you
have regularization on the weights and
that gives you some interpretation so I
don't have time to go over that right
now but feel free to ask me later
there's another flossed function do you
have a question yeah so why do you
choose the margin so in classification
we're going to look at the margin
because that tells you how confidently
you're predicting correctly in
regression you're gonna look at
residuals and square losses so it
depends on the kind of what problems
you're trying to solve just really
quickly some of you might have heard of
logistic regression logistic regression
is this yellow loss function right so
the point of this is saying that this
loss minimization framework is you know
really general and a lot of things that
you might have heard of least squares
let's just regression aren't kind of
special cases of this so if you kind of
master how they do lots of an
organization you kind of can do at all
ok so summary basically what's on the
board here
if you're doing classification you take
the score which comes from W of X and
you drive it into the sign and then you
get either plus 1 or minus 1 regression
you just use a score now to train you
have to assess how well you're doing
classification there's the notion of a
margin in regression it's the residual
and then you can define loss functions
and here's we only talk about five loss
functions but there's many others
especially for a kind of structure
prediction or ranking problems there's
all sorts of different loss functions
but they're kind of based on these
simple ideas of you know where you have
a hinge that helper balance to 0 1 if
you're doing classification and some
sort of square like error for you know
regression and then once you have your
loss functions provide it's not 0 1 you
can optimize it using SJD which turns
out to be a lot faster than gradient
descent ok so next time we're going to
talk about V of X which we've kind of
left as you know someone just hands it
to you and then we're also going to talk
about what is it really true objective
of machine learning is it really to
optimize that training ok until next
time